la première fois que je suis parti à
l'UMD de Cadillac j'avais peur
UMD ça veut dire unité pour malade
difficile
on y soigne ceux qui sont dangereux pour
la société
à 40 km de Bordeaux celle de Cadillac
est l'une des plus anciennes
depuis 1963 c'est une forteresse
des murs de 3 mètres de haut doublé de
grillage
[Musique]
derrière 90 patients seulement des
hommes enfermés de force
[Musique]
Jacques sorti et chaque entrée sont
strictement contrôlées
pour pénétrer dans ce monde clos un
monde dans un monde
il faut un badge magnétique et franchir
le double sas de sécurité
pourtant la première chose qui frappe
quand on entre ici
[Musique]
c'est le silence
37000 mètres carrés de cour grillager et
de bâtiments au début on s'y perd
les malades sont répartis dans cinq
unités
dans l'une d'elles il y a un homme qui
vient d'arriver
Philippe à 50 ans
il vivait seul dans une petite ville de
l'ouest de la France
avant il était facteur
mais il sentait bien que quelque chose
n'allait pas chez lui
un jour il a failli tuer
j'ai des flottements dans la tête
mais quelque chose de pas stable dans
mon esprit dans ma tête
j'ai agressé mon voisin avec une arme
blanche
donc
j'aurais pu aller en prison
j'ai été déclaré irresponsable dès le
début parce que vous avez mon délire
je projetais des des fantasmes sur une
personne mais à un point très très élevé
c'était pour une femme
je pensais qu'il était un obstacle à ma
relation avec elle
est une interférence
parce que je prédendais communiquer avec
elle par télépathie
quand je voulais m'adresser à elle c'est
lui qui répondait à travers le black
présent du plancher
cette femme
une histoire sociale
elle m'a crevé les yeux
elle m'a dit je t'aime avec les yeux
et là tout ça c'est faux
la femme et moi nous n'avons pas de
relation
j'ai pas voulu le tuer
il n'avait rien fait
de tomber sur moi
comme Philippe en France 600 patients
sont hospitalisés dans des unités pour
malades difficiles
certains ont alimenté des faits divers
retentissants
ces actes font d'autant plus peur qu'on
ne les comprend pas
[Musique]
la plupart de ces meurtriers n'ont pas
eu de procès la loi considère qu'on ne
peut pas juger selon le discernement
était aboli au moment des faits
[Musique]
c'est pour eux qu'à la fin des années 40
on a créé ces lieux
entreprise ont et hôpital
leur protocole de soins est intensif
leur cadre hyper sécurisé
dans les chambres les meubles sont
scellés
cet univers quasi carcéral ce n'est pas
pour les punir mais pas nécessité tout
pourrait servir d'armes à ces hommes
parce qu'ils sont tenus au secret
médical les soignants n'ont pas le droit
de nous dire pourquoi les malades sont
là
alors ce sont eux qui nous ont raconté
leur histoire
au sein de l'UMD nous avons installé un
studio et ces hommes qui ont du mal à
s'exprimer ce sont livrés
la plupart sont sous tutelles ils ont
négocié le droit de se montrer
les autres nous les avons filmés dans la
pénombre
nous avons changé leur prénom
pendant des mois nous avons partagé leur
quotidien
nous avons découvert comment leur
psychiatre les ramène à la réalité
leur face à face avec le juge leur
dernier recours pour être libérés
me les a volés nous avons rencontré des
mères désemparés quand elles ont
découvert la maladie de leur enfant
se battre comme ça dans le vide une
musique couche-toi maman ils vont te
faire mal
à l'écart de la société ces hommes
passent parfois des dizaines d'années au
sein de ces unités
prisonnier des murs mais aussi de leur
folie
nous avons voulu savoir qui ils sont
[Musique]
avant la construction de l'UMD dans la
région Cadillac était déjà célèbre pour
ses fous
la ville qui compte 3000 habitants peut
accueillir plus de 800 malades mentaux
on en croit souvent dans ces rues
ils sont soignés à l'hôpital
psychiatrique situé en plein centre
depuis toujours son histoire est liée à
celle de la folie
au 18e siècle on l'appelle la ville
d'aliénés et il reçoit ses premiers
patients des nobles tombés en état de
démence enfermé ici à la demande de leur
famille
[Musique]
en 1918 ce sont d'anciens poilus
la société ne sait pas quoi faire de ces
hommes revenus traumatisés du front à
l'époque on ne sait pas les soigner
le cimetière de la ville porte les
vestiges de cette histoire avec son
carré appelé celui des fous ou encore
celui des oubliés
[Musique]
900 croix alignés la plupart sont pierre
tombale aujourd'hui on ne sait plus très
bien qui est enterré là
pour malade difficile a été construite
le long de ce cimetière
là-bas tous les matins c'est le même
rituel
il est presque 8 heures l'heure de
réveiller les patients
ils ont passé la nuit enfermé à clé dans
leur chambre
répartis en dortoir de 4 dans ce
bâtiment ils sont 16
ils viennent de toute la France ils ont
entre 24 et 68 ans
avant de les filmer nous avons passé du
temps avec eux sans caméra pour faire
connaissance et qu'il s'habituer à notre
présence
certains sont imprévisibles
leur maladie les entraîner si loin
qu'ils ont besoin d'une surveillance et
de soins spécifiques
à l'UMP et c'est un luxe en psychiatrie
il y a un soignant pour six patients
[Musique]
les infirmiers sont au plus près des
malades ils partagent leur quotidien
le réveil est un moment essentiel il
permet de capter l'humeur de jour et de
fixer le cadre dès le matin
nous disent bonjour qui nous regarde
dans les yeux
des petites choses comme ça quand même
on vérifie
si ça va bien se passer ensuite ou pas
pour nous c'est un moment de prise de
contact c'est le moment d'observation
donc on les regarde en fait et puis on
voit voilà s'ils sont bien organisés si
je choisis bien ses affaires s'il y a
pas de tension entre
s'il est bien réveillé si je sais pas
s'il est pas trop triste il y a plein de
choses
comment ça va aujourd'hui
ce matin
depuis qu'il est tout jeune Daniel
souffre de troubles obsessionnels
compulsifs dans le passé c'est toc
l'auront du violon ça fait 11 ans qu'il
vit dans cette unité
ici c'est l'un des plus fragiles
ce matin il est encore plus angoissé que
d'habitude
peut-être à cause de la présence
derrière lui de Karim
les pouces levés lui est à Cadillac
depuis 6 mois c'est l'un de plus agité
du groupe
excité par la caméra
c'est en tout cas celui que l'on entend
le plus
déjà ça pour moi il y a trop de bruit ça
résonne tout ça et ça peut gêner
il sait rien de mal mais ça peut gêner
chez certains la maladie se manifeste
par des hallucinations auditives
autrement dit ils entendent des voix
pour eux le bruit encore plus que pour
nous est un facteur de stress
[Musique]
parfois il y en a qui demandent à rester
une heure au calme en chambre
d'isolement car ils ont peur de même et
de ce son qui résonne
[Musique]
les autres vont prendre leur petit
déjeuner dans le réfectoire
pour rythmer la journée aucune sonnerie
mais des portes qui se ferment toujours
à clé
l'emploi du temps chaque jour le même et
millimétré
comme les médicaments cela fait partie
de la thérapie
[Musique]
ce rapport au temps permet d'en créer
les malades dans la réalité
le moindre changement d'habitude
risquerait de le perturber
plus vrai pour les patients qui
souffrent de troubles obsessionnels
comme Daniel
[Musique]
quand il était petit on ne connaissait
pas sa maladie
il nous a raconté qu'à l'hôpital on
disait à ses parents votre fils est
juste cinglé
à 48 ans il n'a jamais pu construire sa
vie
il ne souffre d'aucune pathologie
physique mais il est malade depuis tant
d'années que peu à peu son corps est
devenu le reflet de son cerveau
chaotique
ce sont des angoisses incroyables des
souffrances incroyables
Daniel dois-je ses propres symptômes
mais ici il doit aussi supporter ce des
autres
les règles strictes les mêmes pour tous
prendre possibles une vie en communauté
qui n'ont pas choisi
on les récupère parce que vous jouez
avec et vous n'avez rien à faire avec
dans le service dans la cour et encore
si ça se passe bien
mais il y a des moments où la moindre
contrariété rend insupportable cette
cohabitation forcée
qu'est-ce qui se passe ailleurs
triste
tu sais où tu es ici
attention à tes propos
je sais que tu es qu'un passé comme ça
hyper violent d'accord mais tu as changé
ça fait un moment que tu as pas mis un
tir à quelqu'un c'est combien de temps
tu sais à peu près combien de temps ça
fait que tu t'es pas énervé contre à
soignant ou contre un patient
autant moi on joue on en est
donc pendant tout ce chemin tu as pris
qu'il y avait des alternatives plutôt
que mettre des coups à des patients
quand on sent qu'il t'énervent de trop
c'était quoi ces alternatives
c'est quoi
à ce jour ton problème c'est plus la
violence c'est les tocs
comme Daniel la plupart des patients ont
des problèmes d'élocution les
traitements et les troubles mentaux
ralentissent les mouvements
ils altèrent aussi les capacités
d'organisation la concentration la
mémoire et l'apprentissage
pour les préserver l'UMD propose des
ateliers d'ergothérapie
ergothérapie ça veut dire soigner par
l'activité
hors du cadre formel des unités ces
travaux manuels permettent aussi de
libérer la parole et d'occuper l'esprit
à autre chose qu'à la maladie
ce raccord médical les patients ont même
le droit à l'outillage
les malades choisissent leur activité
Stéphanie fait partie de l'équipe
d'ergothérapie tous les jours elle va le
chercher car ils n'ont pas le droit de
sortir seul de leurs unités
Jean-Pierre vous prenez votre manteau
Daniel pour Daniel et les autres ces
rendez-vous
allez-y c'est un peu comme une bouffée
d'air frais
Stéphanie travaille ici depuis 15 ans
le plus important pour elle c'est la
confiance mutuelle qu'elle a
progressivement réussi à instaurer avec
les patients
de Monaco
elle nous confie qu'elle n'en a jamais
eu peur
il va nous en faire trois tonnes
Jean-Pierre
depuis toujours Jean-Pierre adore jouer
les divas
il était unique conne de la nuit
bordelaise
quand il vient ici il aime se souvenir
de sa vie d'avant moi j'ai réalisé une
statue de Michel Polnareff avenue
lunettes et tout voilà
club parce que je travaillais avant dans
les clubs des clubs que je suis disco
choqué
pour ces hommes rejetés et stigmatisés
par la société
fabriquer des objets dont ils sont fiers
se retrouver un peu d'estime de même
mais l'accès à ses ateliers ne leur ai
permis qu'après plusieurs semaines
d'observation
vous rappelez comment on fait ce n'est
que lorsque les médecins et les
infirmiers estiment qu'ils sont prêts
à utiliser des outils même les plus
tranchants et ça n'a jamais posé
problème c'est bon
nous avons
tous les outils
les ciseaux les cutter et tout alors son
était dangereux comme on dit comme comme
le répète mais on aurait pris un truc
non mais non non
on montre qu'on n'est pas tout ça qu'on
dit qu'on était dangereux que si c'est
pas possible
[Musique]
on ne sait pas qui Daniel a tenté
d'assassiner
c'était il y a longtemps mais il sait
qu'il a toujours besoin d'aide
Jean-Pierre lui est un délinquant sexuel
parce qu'il n'a jamais tenté de tuer il
ne veut pas comprendre ce qu'il fait là
je vois comme montre que je suis pas
tout ça qu'on dit
non mais c'est vrai il y a des gens que
l'on enferme comme ça
voilà un peu
voilà
[Musique]
on ferme plutôt pour les pour les
détruire parce que il y a parce que la
société ne veut pas accepter
les mots que voilà les mots qu'on dit et
oui
allez-y
Daniel hospitalisé en psychiatrie depuis
plus de 10 ans Jean-Pierre en est à son
huitième séjour en UMD
[Musique]
oui
les depuis qu'il est revenu ici il y a
un an il multiplie les recours contre
une hospitalisation qu'il considère
comme abusive
cet après-midi il a demandé un entretien
à sa psychiatre
le docteur floriste le sud depuis 3 ans
quand les patients quittent ils
retournent dans leur hôpital
psychiatrique d'origine
la dernière fois qu'on a laissé sortir
Jean-Pierre au bout de seulement 5 jours
il aurait de nouveau agressé un patient
l'entretien a lieu en présence d'une
interne et d'une infirmière
[Musique]
j'étais coupé de tout le monde extérieur
je suis désolé mais vous n'êtes pas
revenu par hasard à l'UMD
après vous êtes suffisamment intelligent
pour être capable de travailler sur
votre problématique le problème c'est
qu'à ce jour vous ne l'acceptez pas vous
l'accepter un jour sur deux
je travaille sur moi
mais tant mieux
je peux
stopper ça comment j'arrive à stopper
mon
voilà donc ce qui est quand même
intéressant dans ce que j'entends c'est
que si vous travaillez sur vous-même
pour essayer de mieux gérer votre vous
vos pulsions sexuelles c'est que vous
identifiez qu'elle pose problème
mais c'est pas d'avoir des envies
sexuelles qui posent problème on l'a
déjà travaillé ensemble ça c'est normal
d'avoir des envies c'est après comme on
les gère
si vous avez quand même des difficultés
à interpréter les choix de l'autre
[Musique]
les choix de l'autre enfin la position
de l'autre parce qu'on en avait parlé
c'est pas parce qu'il vous il vous dit
bonjour et qui vous parle qu'il est
intéressant pour aller qu'il est
intéressé pour aller plus loin tout ça
une seconde que vous avez été
suffisamment naïf pour penser
au sujet d'accord vous saviez quelque
part
qu'il était pas forcément d'accord mais
qu'il allait pas s'opposer
donc au bénéfice du doute ça se tentait
on est d'accord il y avait pas de
méchanceté d'austérité en soi là-dedans
sauf que vous mesurez pas que ça peut
être extrêmement traumatisant pour la
personne en face
parce que vous vous substituez à propre
au désir vous supposez que le désir est
partagé et là vous êtes juste trompé à
nouveau trompé
donc ça s'appelle
une agression sexuelle
est beaucoup plus vaste qu'un problème
de libido
il y a une quête affective très
importante derrière tout ça il y a très
franchement moi j'ai du mal aujourd'hui
à me projeter dans l'idée de
d'envisager qu'il est suffisamment
évolué pour le faire sortir on pourrait
dire allez on lui laisse encore mais lui
c'est encore une chance c'est quoi
qui vient c'est le huitième séjour
je pense que non on a un des médicaments
pour contrôler les hormones et mais je
pense que ça ne changerait rien ils se
sentirait à mon avis dévalorisé diminuer
castrer je crois que là pour le coup le
peu de liens qu'on a réussi à construire
avec lui on le perdrait
[Musique]
c'est parfois compliqué de distinguer ce
qui relève de la maladie de ce qui est
lié à l'histoire et à la personnalité
des patients
dans les UMD la plupart sont atteints de
psychose des pathologies psychiatriques
qui entraînent une distorsion de la
réalité
leur origine est mal connue
elle serait en partie liée à un
déséquilibre des molécules chimiques qui
communiquent par électricité les
informations au cerveau
ces molécules ce sont les
neurotransmetteurs
ils gèrent entre autres le sommeil
l'agressivité et l'humeur
chez les psychotiques ces molécules
peuvent transmettre de faux messages au
cerveau
il y a plusieurs types de psychose mais
la plus fréquente ici c'est la
schizophrénie
réduite à tort un dédoublement de la
personnalité elle est en réalité plus
complexe
parce qu'ils ont une maladie qui fait
qu'on perd complètement le sens du réel
on croit que quelque chose est vrai
alors que c'est une coïncidence
hasardeuse on croit ressentir les choses
on croit entendre de voir
j'entends des voix je suis tellement
seul des fois que je repense à mes amis
je leur parle dans ma tête et je parle à
mes potes comme si j'étais au téléphone
je dis wesh alors comment ça va il me
dit ouais
comme ça et ça continue comme ça tout le
temps
non je sais pas parce que c'est mal vu
ici
outre ses hallucinations la
schizophrénie se manifeste par des
comportements et des idées bizarres ce
qu'on appelle les délires parfois il
prête à sourire
des espèces d'insectes en genre des
trèfles dorés et un autre insecte qui
avait une espèce de crédit jaune avec un
corps rouge et des pieds bleus si je
vous explose
et ça a rendu complètement folle
mais il faut comprendre que les patients
croient réellement que ce qu'ils
vivaient vrai
coupé du monde dans une autre réalité
qui les isole des autres
certains seront fermés complètement sur
eux-mêmes
ce qu'il ressentent et entendent
peut-être terriblement angoissant
il y en a qui ont la sensation de
pourrir sur place
d'autres qui sont pris dans des délires
de persécution
j'étais pas malade
il parle de moi
[Musique]
tout seul contre tout ça
dans leur certitude souvent les patients
n'ont pas conscience d'être malade
qu'ils ont besoin d'aide
mais s'ils sont ici c'est qu'à un moment
donné leur folie à atteint quelqu'un
d'autre et qu'ils ont tué des gestes de
violence
pas mal ce que vous avez fait
dans les unités comme ici à
l'ergothérapie les soignants essayent de
les ramener doucement à la réalité
pour vous vous êtes malade ou pas
d'après vous vous auriez dû être parce
que vous avez pas votre place ici
d'accord si vous deviez dire
dans quel contexte pour quelles raisons
vous êtes arrivés ici sans faire exprès
casser de côté inférieur
[Musique]
pour cette épisode
donc pour vous ce qui est plus simple
j'ai cassé ma chambre
un coup de poing que j'ai donné à mon
pote dans la figure
donc du coup ces épisodes de violence
vous les attribuez à quoi vous c'était
pas une adverton et qu'est-ce qui vous
dit que ça va pas se reproduire
j'ai bien vu le taux que j'avais atteint
pour pour arriver à ça quoi vous
comprenez que le médecin du service
d'origine les médecins qui sont ici qui
vont se prononcer sur votre sortie vous
avez besoin de garantie par rapport à ça
vous le comprenez ou pas non je le
comprends pas
faire prendre conscience au patients de
leur maladie et de la gravité de leurs
actes peut prendre des années
affronter la réalité et parfois trop dur
à supporter chez les schizophrènes le
suicide et la première cause de
mortalité
il y a 20 ans Pierre a tué sans raison
une infirmière
quand il a recouvré ses esprits et
réaliser ce qu'il avait fait il est
tombé en profonde dépression
c'est passé dans un fouet thérapeutique
elle était à la cuisine
qui était sévère
et
j'ai tué
je pensais pas que je vais planter la 5
coups j'étais jeune j'avais 22 ans à
l'époque et je m'en veux et ça m'a
bouleversé dans la vie quoi ça
m'a bouleversé quoi j'aimais bien cette
personne on allait au cinéma on allait
au restaurant et personne bien quoi et
moi j'ai déjà monté
cette douleur
c'est dur de vivre avec un mars le bras
je regrette surtout
ne méritait pas ça maintenant
psychiatriques ou être incarcéré tous
ces hommes ont été placés en UMD à la
demande du préfet
pour en sortir c'est une commission de
psychiatre indépendant qui se prononce
mais depuis quelques années la justice
aussi peut intervenir
[Musique]
aujourd'hui Michel a mis sa veste du
dimanche il est à Cadillac depuis deux
ans elle va justement tenter de
convaincre un tribunal de le faire
libérer
l'audience doit avoir lieu à 200 mètres
à peine de l'UMD mais c'est le protocole
pour prévenir tout risque d'évasion
chaque trajet doit s'effectue en
ambulance avec la présence d'au moins de
soignants
et le préfet doit en être informé 48
heures à l'avance minimum
des mesures de sécurité trop
contraignantes pour conduire les malades
jusqu'à Bordeaux
Michel a rendez-vous à l'hôpital
psychiatrique de Cadillac ou une annexe
de tribunal a été aménagée
deux jours plus tôt
nous l'avions rencontré dans son unité
il a 46 ans il n'a pas commis
d'orthographe mais son état est si
délirant qu'il perturbait son hôpital
psychiatrique d'origine
perso d'avoir gagné une fortune loto et
qu’on l’empêche de toucher ses gains
tout de suite il donne le ton entretien
[Musique]
une dent à micro
j'ai toujours des paroles en permanence
des gens qui me
regarde
fils de [__]
pire qu'un téléphone ou on reçoit
l'espace parce que là je peux pas régler
est-ce que vous pouvez la répondre
Michel est toujours passée d'hôpital en
hôpital il ressent l'audience
d'aujourd'hui comme un moment capital
depuis 2011 les passages des patients
devront la justice ont obligatoire tous
les six mois
ils permettent de s'assurer qu'on
enferme pas les malades à tort
ce sont les juges de la liberté et de la
détention qui éveillent
il statue sur tout type
d'hospitalisation forcée en hôpital
classique comme en UMD
l'année dernière en France près de 100
000 patients ont été internés contre
leur gré
les juges n'ont aucune formation
psychiatrique mais il servent de
garde-fou en contrôlant que les droits
des patients sont respectés par des
médecins qui autrefois étaient
tout-puissant
Michel est assisté d'une avocate commise
d'office
toujours l'audience est publique
tout le monde a le droit d'y assister
l'auto et la France
de l'unité de l'hôpital
[Musique]
donc si
vous avez une vie
au Château de Divonne
que
je pense que ma mère a dû acheter enfin
je vois avec les notaires parce que ma
mère est morte mon père est mort mes
grands-parents sont morts mon grand-père
m'avait laissé 250 2500 millions
[Musique]
il est ouvert au public c'est un hôtel
proche qui voudrait m'épouser mais c'est
toujours délicat dans ce cas là parce
que l'inceste mais bon c'est des petites
cousines et des petits
cousines et des copines que j'ai eu qui
sont sympas
on ne connaît pas sa famille
l'audience a duré 20 minutes
l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est qu'on est
écouté
bonne fin de journée et puis on espère
que tu dois réussir à sortir
la juge a rendu sa décision dans
l'après-midi elle a maintenu Michel à
l'UMP
depuis quelle statut sur les
hospitalisations sous contrainte elle
n'a jamais décelé début Acadie
[Musique]
dans les unités pour malades difficiles
la durée moyenne de ces jours est de 8
mois mais pour certains c'est presque
toute une vie
[Musique]
à 41 ans
eric n'a jamais été marié il n'a pas eu
d'enfant
à l'UMD il a un statut particulier
responsabilisé par la justice il a été
condamné à 20 ans de prison pour acte de
barbarie
il purge ici sa peine
c'est 15 ans que je suis enfermé
je suis en prison
même
je t'ai rationnel j'ai un comportement
étrange
j'avais j'étais pas comme tout le monde
et on vous a dit ce que vous aviez quand
vous arrivez
schizophrène et bipolaire
moi je pense que la maladie je la traîne
depuis pas mal de temps vu l'enfance que
j'ai eu
j'avais beaucoup eu de problèmes à
l'extérioriser ce que je ressentais
j'avais un double moi un petit moment
qui dit ça
les premiers symptômes d'Eric
apparaissent à la fin de l'adolescence
il commence à fumer du cannabis
une drogue dont on sait aujourd'hui
qu'elle peut révéler une schizophrénie
chez certains sujets fragiles
peu à peu ils s'enferme dans un autre
monde et se marginalise
j'ai un appartement un travail une amie
les parents qui me soutenaient
une famille
puis du jour au lendemain je suis parti
avec
un moment d'égard où je me suis orienté
vers les stupéfiants et j'étais foudroyé
par cette drogue
[Musique]
quand leur enfant est schizophrène ce
sont toujours les parents qui sont en
première ligne
la schizophrénie est une maladie encore
mal connue qui fait peur
souvent ils ont honte d'en parler
[Musique]
à une centaine de kilomètres de là en
Charente
la mère d'Eric elle a eu le courage de
témoigner à visage découvert
claudia est très proche de son fils
même dans les pires moments elle ne l'a
jamais lâché
je l'ai partout
il me suit
partout sur les la
il est là
voilà
voilà il était tout jeune heureux très
heureux happy
très très joyeux joyeux et aimant très
doux très intelligent très très doué en
tout
les parents d'Éric ce sont séparés quand
il était petit
avec sa sœur Agnès et sa mère il forme
un trio fusionnel
claudia est infirmière elle ne roule pas
sur l'or
mais il ne manque ni d'argent ni d'amour
il a 16 ans quand tout commence à
déraper
il y avait une petite amie parisienne
qui fumait qui se droguait qui se
piquait et puis petit à petit
Erika a suivi le mouvement voilà j'étais
très longue très très longue à me rendre
compte très longue jusqu'au jour où je
l'ai vu se battre comme ça dans le vide
une musique couche-toi maman ils vont te
faire mal couche-toi couche-toi ils sont
là regarde ils sont des couteaux là il
avait des hallucinations et là j'ai
compris
Claudia comprend que son fils se drogue
les aligner encore qu'avec ses
hallucinations c'est la maladie qui
commence à s'exprimer
Eric arrête ses études et sombre dans la
petite délinquance
un jour de Noël il ne reconnaît plus ni
sa mère ni sa sœur
c'était plus lui c'était plus lui il
nous a pris pour des voleuses moi
j'étais une femme qui voulait venir
voler l'âme de sa mère donc Agnès Agnès
m'a défendu parce qu'Eric m'a frappé il
a pris une fourchette à rôti et il a
frappé sa soeur il a mis la main dans la
bouche pour qu'elle ne crie pas il lui a
planté la fourchette
et ma fille était enceinte
elle a perdu son bébé donc tout ça sont
des choses très difficiles
Agnès a voulu protéger son frère et n'a
pas porté plainte
pendant des années Claudia avait le
calvaire des parents qui ont des enfants
différents
elle cherche du secours auprès des
pouvoirs publics et des institutions
mais personne ne semble pouvoir l'aider
les pompiers me renvoyaient à la
gendarmerie la gendarmerie dans un
hôpital l'hôpital me disait consulter le
médecin avec lui en fait je tournais
sans arrêt sans arrêt sans arrêt son
fils fait peur même ses amis
l'abandonnent
je pouvais plus compter sur personne
non personne et quand j'en parlais on
disait écoute
mets-le à la porte tu donnes pas à
manger il reviendra pas
il y a une personne qui m'a dit un jour
mais moi je le fusillerai si j'avais un
fusil je le fusillerai
et plus je crois on me disait ça plus
j'avais envie de l'aider je voulais
qu'il s'en sorte j'ai vraiment porté à
bout de bras à bout de bras
et leur a fallu presque 6 ans avant
qu'une psychiatre ne pose un diagnostic
et annonce à sa mère que son fils
schizophrène
le monde s'est écroulé le monde s'est
écroulé
elle s'est levée de son siège elle m'a
prise dans ses bras et elle me dit vous
savez contre la schizophrénie il faut
absolument que votre fils accepte de se
faire soigner et les majeurs
il ne veut pas donc il y a qu'une chose
c'est à temps malheureusement qu'il
fasse du mal à quelqu'un
[Musique]
emporté par sa folie un jour
Eric se met en tête qu'un ami de la
famille veut du mal à sa mère
ce n'est pas vrai mais croyons la
protéger il va chez lui et lui plant un
couteau dans l'oeil
j'ai pris de du vin rouge
je suis rentré chez lui
j'ai décompensé tout simplement ça veut
dire quoi de compenser c'est perdre
toutes ces possibilités mentales et
physiques
j'étais dans le néant je vais dans un
néant
je me suis retrouvé condamné à un temps
de prison
et moi ces années j'ai 27 ans
ce tableau a été offert à l'UMP par sa
mère
quand il est arrivé ici
Eric était trop malade pour avoir des
contacts avec l'extérieur elle trouve ce
moyen de lui faire savoir qu'elle est
toujours là
[Musique]
avec ce petit présente fera du bien au
moral pendant ton absence ta maman qui
t'aime et qui pense toujours à toi même
très très loin géographiquement
submerable
quand je partirai
[Musique]
sa main soulagée vraiment soulagée je
savais que plus personne pouvait le
faire du mal et que lui non plus en fait
[Musique]
j'ai la chance de maman comme ça
Agnès elle me dit je l'aime j'aime mon
frère quand elle en parle elle est allé
le voir quelquefois mais maintenant
qu'elle a ses trois enfants veut
protéger ses enfants et elle revoit la
scène la scène quand elle lui mettait la
fourchette à rôtie dans la bouche
qu'il fallait la tuer que
et mais elle me demande toujours des
nouvelles d'Eric elle lui fait des
cadeaux pour son anniversaire son Noël
mais elle a peur même s'il est en lieu
sécurisé à la peur elle ne veut plus
elle veut pas le voir elle ne peut pas
ce qu'elle ne peut plus
enfin soigner
eric n'a plus de délire et ses médecins
estiment qu'il n'est plus dangereux
mais pour pouvoir quitter l'UMD il doit
demander une libération conditionnelle à
la justice
il sera bientôt si elle est accepté
[Musique]
le vendredi c'est le jour de la cantine
un terme hérité de l'univers carcéral
à tour de rôle les patients vont
récupérer ce qu'ils ont pu commander et
acheter avec l'autorisation de l'équipe
médicale
[Musique]
la plupart vivent d'allocations adultes
handicapées soit environ 800 euros par
mois
avec cette somme géré par leur tutelle
ils peuvent se procurer leurs produits
d'hygiène et leur tabac
mais aussi de quoi améliorer l'ordinaire
ici c'est l'un de leurs seuls plaisir
merci Philippe lance un facteur s'est
offert des cigares
peu à peu il s'habitue à son nouvel
univers
pendant ce temps Daniel le patient qui
souffre de TOC est un entretien médical
ferreux d'informations
la politique et le sport
dans sa chambre il peut écouter la radio
jusqu'à 22h mais c'est la coupe
européenne de football il voudrait
suivre le match de ce soir jusqu'au bout
sont beaucoup plus tard que
mes horaires de radio de juin est-ce que
je peux 23h30 comme je veux voir
le
[Musique]
d'accord
est-ce que j'ai déjà répondu à cette
question
donc c'est bon
il peut poser la même question pendant
des heures
j'ai rien compris la redresse vous et
ces articuler parce que là je comprends
rien merci
[Musique]
ça marche pas de souci
on fait comme ça vous pouvez regarder le
foot
[Musique]
d'aménager les horaires pour ce soir
allez on s'arrête là parce que vous
allez me redemander une fois de plus et
je vous aurais dit que je vous ai déjà
répondu ok bonne journée on se revoit
bientôt
ces idées obsessionnelles c'est un peu
comme une forteresse mentale ce serait
construite pour se protéger des
angoisses
le psychotique c'est comme si le
manquait une enveloppe contre le comme
si il manquait une sorte d'enveloppe
entre lui le monde qui régule il se
retrouve finalement complètement
complètement
explosé complètement morcelé même les
limites corporelles sont difficiles à
percevoir les limites psychiques encore
plus et lui en fait a mis en place une
espèce de défense une espèce de d'armure
en fait constituée par tous ces rituels
tous ces tocs tout ça qui contient bien
sa psychose donc le but c'est pas non
plus de fragiliser cette armure parce
qu'elle lui est quand même très utile
mais elle l'enferme en même temps donc
il faut réussir à trouver un compromis
entre ça ça ne le contraigne pas trop
que ça ne l'empêche pas non plus vivre
et d'évoluer mais en respectant ses
défenses parce que ces défenses elles
lui sont extrêmement utiles elles
évitent l'explosion
[Musique]
la médecine ne s'est pas encore guérir
les psychoses mais elle sait en
contrôler les symptômes
c'est bientôt l'heure du coucher et les
infirmiers préparent les médicaments du
soir
tout ça ce sont des neuroleptiques ou
des antipsychotiques pour ajuster les
doses au plus près
sans doute
la plupart des médicaments se donnent
sous forme de solution buvables
et les anti-psychotiques ce sont des
tranquillisants super puissants
mais ici on essaie de soigner sans
assommer
c'est quelque chose qui va permettre de
contrôler les hallucinations et de
contrôler le délire du patient et
éventuellement son état de tension
sans ces médicaments les patients
risqueraient de passer de nouveau à
l'acte
trois fois par jour il les prennent sous
la stricte surveillance de l'équipe
soignante
ou l'hypertension les psychos sont des
maladies chroniques qui nécessitent un
traitement à vie
mais la difficulté de ces pathologies
c'est de le faire comprendre à des
malades qui souvent n'ont pas conscience
de l'être
sans savoir
tes idées je les respecte là c'est pas
le moment de les déballer donc je te
propose celui-là demain matin on se voit
en entretien pour débriefer ça est-ce
qu'on peut forcer un patient à prendre
ses médicaments c'est toute la
difficulté de notre travail ils sont à
la fois juridiquement ils sont sous
contrainte
mais à la fois est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment forcer
je vais peut-être honnête avec vous on
cherche pas à forcer mais on va essayer
de le convaincre que c'est dans son
intérêt de le prendre
on va lui mettre la pression on va dire
mais si vous continuez comme ça et si
vous êtes menaçant et si vous refusez
votre traitement de toute façon c'est
prévu nous on n'a pas besoin de demander
votre avis on a une injection qui est
prévue on a une isolement qui est prévu
on a des contentions qui sont prévues
dans ces couloirs deux chambres
d'isolement
ce jour-là elles sont vides
ici les soignants privilégient toujours
la pédagogie à la force
c'est ta prescription l'une de leurs
premières mission c'est d'éduquer ses
hommes à leur maladie de leur apprendre
à vivre avec
le but qu'il continue leur traitement à
l'extérieur en acceptant les effets
secondaires
problèmes de poids ou des locutions ils
sont importants mais dépendent de chacun
avant de trouver le traitement le plus
adapté à chaque patient il faut tester
plusieurs médicaments
c'est un travail de longue haleine
grâce à ma nouvelle molécule je suis
content
ça ça change ma vie
sans vous dire j'ai la tête en fait à
les médicaments qui sont un peu
qui jouent sur le cerveau
il me faut vraiment beaucoup de ça ça me
fait planer ça
dans le hall Daniel a son poste de radio
mais il est de nouveau pris par ces toc
[Musique]
les médicaments ne font pas toujours des
miracles mais ils arrivent à soulager
ses angoisses et c'est déjà beaucoup
[Musique]
avant de monter à l'étage les patients
récupèrent à tour de rôle leurs affaires
pour la nuit
[Musique]
l'hôpital met alors disposition des
pyjamas ils achètent le reste de leurs
vêtements via la cantine ou lors de
sortie thérapeutique
totalement pris en charge les malades
font parfois penser à de grands enfants
à faire Daniel prends ta douche ou pas
c'est demain matin demain matin
de l'image parentale qui rassure
mais qui doit aussi savoir saisir quand
il faut
avant Jean-Pierre se tenait les cheveux
en blond pour ressembler à Michel
Polnareff ici c'est interdit mais il a
voulu se poser un masque capillaire
[Musique]
on va pas passer toute la nuit avec ça
sur la tronche
le matin
vous laissez ça dans vos cheveux
vous allez vous rincer les cheveux tout
de suite s'il te plaît
la plupart du temps tu te laisses aller
tu te comportes comme un punk et là ce
soir tu nous fais un masque de cheveux
quoi
avec une tonne de crème sur la tête
le moindre incident comme celui qui
vient de se produire avec Jean-Pierre et
consigner
ainsi toute l'équipe médicale est au
courant
tous les soirs les malades sont enfermés
dans leur chambre pour protéger les
autres mais aussi pour se protéger de
même
les lumières doivent s'éteindre à 21h
précises
[Musique]
est-ce que vous rêvez la nuit
j'avais rêvé que mon lit
s'est décollé du sol et qui est passé
par la fenêtre et je me baladais
qu'est-ce qui vous manque ici
[Musique]
il y a plein de choses qui me manquent
l'amour
je suis un humain
[Musique]
voilà
la nuit les angoisses se réveillent
le manque d'amour d'une femme le manque
d'amour d'une mère les souvenirs qui
reviennent et qui ravivent les pensées
suicidaires
ce soir-là les infirmiers sont
spécialement inquiets pour un patient
le matin
[Musique]
pour se Standler il y a pas de temps il
nous demande d'enlever tout ce qui lui
permettrait de se stranguler ce qui joue
au jeu du foulard
et là en ce moment il le fait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup donc de lui-même là
tout ce qui peut
l'aider à se Strangler nous le donne
pour pas le faire
[Musique]
bref les infirmiers de jour
l'équipe de nuit a pris le relais
[Musique]
le patient que se strangule pour
soulager ses angoisses s'appelle Florent
et la 28 ans il est ici depuis seulement
7 mois mais depuis toujours sa vie était
maillée d'ultra-violence
[Musique]
âge de 16 ans j'ai
pris la tête de quelqu'un j'ai pris sa
tête j'étais classé contre le béton
je l'ai fait parce que voilà
une amie que je respectais beaucoup
j'ai des filles
c'est d'échappement de violence cache
souvent une enfance cabossée et un lourd
passe et psychiatrique
soigné pour des troubles graves du
comportement de l'école primaire Florent
est malade depuis tant d'années que ses
intent souffrances psychiques auront
lieu totalement désespéré
à la place de ma mère
si j'avais eu un fils comme moi et moi
de ma propre façon je me suis
ma mère
mon frère
j'avais envie qu'il leur arrive des
choses je pouvais
vous pouvez je pouvais faire horrible
je faisais ça pour plus pour que ma mère
ne m'aime plus parce qu'elle n'aime plus
couler de larmes en pensant à moi
vous savez dans ma vie je suis toujours
dit la seule façon de tuer l'amour
c'est donner la mort pas la personne
mais à son amour qu'elle a pour vous
c'est fini ma vie
elle est terminée quand est-ce que je
vais le sortirai plus jamais
Florent n'a plus de contact avec sa mère
elle a fini par baisser les bras
[Musique]
le lendemain tout est redevenu calme
c'est un matin comme tant d'autres sauf
qu'aujourd'hui un patient a un
rendez-vous qui risque de bouleverser sa
vie
avant de pouvoir quitter l'UMD ceux qui
ont un statut de détenu doivent avoir
réglé leur compte vis-à-vis de la
justice
ce matin une juge d'application des
peines est venue rencontrer un malade
qui a demandé une libération
conditionnelle
ce patient c'est Éric
condamné à 20 ans de prison pour acte de
barbarie il a déjà passé 15 ans en
détention puis à l'UMD bonjour
unité
elle a été l'une des premières femmes à
travailler à l'UMD
pendant toutes ces années elle a
accompagné
alors on a déjà fait un peu le coin sur
votre situation il y a quelques mois par
rapport à votre demande de libération
conditionnelle et en fin de compte la
semaine dernière
j'ai su que il y a une place qui vous
est réservée très prochainement et que
vous allez partir
en évaluation vous avez bien compris
donc vous devez y aller avant d'être
libéré
Eric doit partir dans un CNE un centre
national d'évaluation
ces centres sont situés en prison dans
des quartiers spécialement aménagés
pendant 6 semaines le comportement
d'Eric sera observé si tout se passe
bien là-bas les médecins pourront
décider de le faire sortir
définitivement de l'UMD l'étape numéro 1
c'était d'avoir une place pour pouvoir
aller dans ce centre d'évaluation
passage obligé compte tenu de des
raisons pour lesquelles vous avez été
condamné oui c'est dans 15 jours il va
falloir vous y préparer voilà voilà
Monsieur
les casquettes c'est interdit ou pas les
cmece d'inquiétude à mon avis vous avez
des capacités d'adaptation qui vous
permettront de vous adapter à ces six
semaines je pense que sur le plan
médical il faut faire confiance à
l'équipe qui s'occupe de vous pour
commencer à vous apprendre à revivre à
l'extérieur
ça c'est déjà une étape essentielle
après 11 ans du MD
eric va peut-être bientôt pouvoir sortir
mais il faut d'abord qu'il s'adapte au
milieu pénitentiaire
Odile le sait ici il a toutes ses
habitudes tous ces repères
on va tout préparer passez une bonne
nouvelle comme elle vous a dit
officieuse on va recevoir le papier
c'est bien
on va recevoir les papiers on va partir
de là organiser au mieux après la balle
est dans votre camp non c'est vous qui
êtes évalué là-bas d'accord c'est pas
nous
donc il va falloir avoir de se poser des
questions sur les casquettes
on va tout organiser avec d'accord c'est
une bonne nouvelle
allez à tout à l'heure on en reparle
tout à l'heure
je suis contente pour lui parce que
c'est le bout du tunnel aussi depuis des
années quoi parce que j'en pense ce à
condamné condamnation c'est
effectivement que c'est un peu ça a été
injuste par rapport à ce patient qui
avant tout malade donc ce qu'il a fait
tout aussi affreux que ce soit c'était
dans un cadre d'une pathologie il a été
condamné très lourdement donc bon là on
avance
le goût du tunnel approche pour lui mais
c'est tant mieux tant mieux tant mieux
pour lui bah oui on les aime bien dans
tous les cas
une fois par an les ergothérapeutes ici
en t-shirt orange organise une sorte de
grande kermesse dans l'enceinte de l'UMP
tous les patients dont l'état le permet
y participent ils sont près de 50
ce sont les Olympiades un moment que
tout s'attendent avec impatience
[Musique]
de la Méduse ce bateau mais que demande
encadrés par les soignants les malades
vont s'affronter pendant une journée
lors de différentes épreuves
les équipes ont été tirées au sort parmi
les cinq unités
pour une fois elles sont mélangées
[Musique]
dans une équipe où vous avez eu deux ans
sur les trois dernières éditions ce
monsieur il a gagné deux fois
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je vous ai dit le plus
important c'est de quoi voilà ici il y a
que des gens qui veulent participer il y
a pas de gens qui veulent gagner
d'accord
on est pas sûr de gagner alors qu'il est
vous êtes sûr de gagner
ou que vous perdez
[Musique]
chacun votre tour vous passez l'année
dernière parce qu'il avait perdu Daniel
était resté prostré pendant des heures
[Musique]
prenez votre temps aujourd'hui les
soignants vont pouvoir mesurer les
progrès accomplis dans l'année
et sa façon de gérer sa frustration s'il
ne gagne pas
c'est l'essentiel
[Musique]
plus qu'une simple compétition les
Olympiades permettent aux malades de
travailler sur eux-mêmes en s'amusant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
loin de l'image des fous du dangereux
aujourd'hui ils sont heureux d'être
ensemble
patient comme soignant
et cela se voit
on se rencontrer c'est que de la
violence la tout prendre les gens on
s'est rencontré
le sourire de Daniel
le fruit de notre travail c'est là qu'on
le voit
ils arrivent à faire ces moments-là
c'est quand ils arrivent justement à
évoluer vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est là qu'on voit
la journée s'achève avec le palmarès
tout le monde gagnera quelque chose
t-shirt ou survêtement
merci
merci Daniel
c'est la douche froide
son équipe n'est que 7e alors qu'il
s'est donné à fond
dès qu'il est contrarié ces tocle
reprennent et son corps marque sa
déception
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e bleue royale
mais cette année ce ne sont pas
seulement ceux qui ont brillé lors des
épreuves qui seront récompensés
[Musique]
l'équipe jaune
[Applaudissements]
sur le banc Daniel s'est renfermé et les
soignants n'ont peut-être senti
pour leur super esprit d'équipe un prix
spécial va être décerné à l'équipe rose
[Applaudissements]
le prix vous êtes encouragé vous avez un
bon esprit pendant tous les toutes les
parties donc voilà on voulait vous
récompenser d'un coup Daniel se redresse
[Applaudissements]
mais la journée s'achève il est temps
pour chacun de retrouver le quotidien
strict de leurs unités
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis l'an dernier Daniel a bien
progressé
son épi n'a pas duré et ses médecins
estiment qu'il est désormais prêt à
franchir de nouvelles étapes peut-être
même hors de l'UMP
[Musique]
Daniel a rendez-vous à l'hôpital de
Cadillac à l'est du tribunal
comme tous les six mois c'est à son tour
de passer devant la juge des libertés
vous vous souvenez de moi
il y a six mois
[Musique]
il était prévu que vous rentriez bientôt
dans votre région d'origine
[Musique]
vous êtes vraiment pas bien aujourd'hui
effectivement vous voulez qu'on arrête
là
[Musique]
pour vous soutenir vous inquiétez pas
aujourd'hui ce qui est sur c'est que ici
il est dans un cas de sécurisant
contenant et qui souhaitent
effectivement rester pour le moment dans
un but de stabiliser et voir ensuite
quel sera
besoin
[Musique]
malgré tout ce que peuvent vous dire les
autres vous vous préférez rester là où
vous êtes au jour d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
donc ma décision il y aura bien que vous
vous voulez rester ici et que pour le
moment c'est le seul endroit où vous
sentiez bien en sécurité
donc vous vous rassurez tant que vous ne
le demanderez pas à partir il y aura pas
de changement
on fera rien contre vous
on fera tout à votre rythme pas un
rythme de quelqu'un d'autre d'accord
très bien bon ben écoutez je vous
souhaite une bonne journée voilà je vous
en rassuré déjà ça va mieux
bonne journée à vous me
merci au revoir au revoir partir du
moment très très longtemps dans un
univers qui comme vous avez pu le voir
c'est quand même assez cocooning je veux
dire tout est fait pour les aider eux à
se comprendre à ce
maîtriser mais dès lors qu'on est en
dehors on a un peu même si vous avez pu
dans dans votre carrière voir des
détenus sur des maisons centrales c'est
à dire des gens qui sont incarcérés
depuis de très très longues années on va
avoir le même phénomène quand la date de
sortie approche c'est à dire ce que je
suis encore adapté
suis-je encore fait pour un monde qui a
continué d'avancer sans moi
suis-je un danger pour les autres
on imagine les questionnements des
malades
dehors
ils sont pas tous gentils des gens pas
comme ici quoi ici on est encadré
de telle sorte qu'il y a aucune violence
il peut y en avoir
un peu
je suis pas très confiant
c'est l'inconnu de
des fois je me dis que je vais sortir
j'ai pas passé mes 30 ans ici
j'ai vraiment pas sortir quand j'ai 30
ans alors que j'ai à 25
ça serait dur
souhaitons que ça soit pas trop long que
je puisse aller au ski en sortant
on a tous un objectif en commun c'est de
sortir la tête haute
cela fait désormais deux semaines qui
récent rencontré l'âge d'application des
peines
il part en prison pour être évalué et
peut-être avoir sa liberté
conditionnelle
[Musique]
avant de quitter l'UMD il voulait dire
au revoir à une personne de l'extérieur
qu'il boit depuis des années tous les
lundis à la même heure
[Musique]
monsieur Lacaze était VRP parce qu'il
s'ennuyait à la retraite il a passé
l'agrément pour devenir visiteur de
prison il est aussi devenu bénévole
auprès des malades de l'UMD
je le ramène un petit peu d'air pur de
l'extérieur quoi de fois il me demande
qu'est-ce qu'il y a autour du de la nuit
partout de la vigne
il y en a avec qui on discute comme on
discute avec vous en ce moment mais
d'autres il faut leur arracher les mots
un petit peu
il y en a qui ne répondent que par OUI
ou pas non et qui demande de ma visite
il y en a certains on se tutoient
un qui pourrait être mon fils
pour le connaissez à Eric il entend
qu'il est là
tous les patients qui le demandent
peuvent recevoir la visite de Monsieur
Lacaze
souvent ce sont ceux qui n'ont plus de
famille
hormis les blouses blanches et ceux qui
représentent la justice
il est la seule personne de l'extérieur
qu'il voit
impressionnant la première fois qu'on
rentre ici
vous allez vous rendre compte par
vous-même
j'ai l'habitude à force
de la maisonerie où c'est très bruyant
ça a été vraiment le contraste c'est
crème médical oblige
[Musique]
monsieur Lacaze ne sait pas pourquoi le
malade sont là lui ne posent pas de
question il attend qu'il se confie
Eric
est le premier patient qui l'a rencontré
bonjour
ça va
il se connaissent depuis 7 ans
alors raconte-moi depuis lundi dernier
tu as commencé à faire ta valise
c'est
le carcéral ils vont ils vont me mettre
à poil ils vont fumer mes affaires
c'est dur ça mais oui c'est le bruit
c'est qu'à l'arrivée c'est la porte pour
la liberté ça
bon séjour là-bas et puis reviens
c'est un peu spécial je sais pas si je
lui apporter quelque chose mais j'ai je
l'ai vu
j'ai vu sa santé s'améliorer vous
pourrez être comme vous l'avez vu
aujourd'hui
donc ça ça ne s'oublie pas
la première fois
et puis tremblait il regardait il
faisait ça là
c'était épicuriez pas
oui il me l'a raconté
c'est dommage
parce que là ça devait être un mec bien
pour la première fois depuis 11 ans
Eric ne dormira pas à lui MD
[Musique]
oui oui
après Éric qu'est-ce que c'est un animal
[Musique]
je sais pas où j'allais ça s'est fait
une vitesse en plus et l'éclair il fait
bizarre non
je pense que je suis fragile
mais ça ne fait pas peur
[Musique]
mais oui je sais pas
ces bons hommes ce sont les agents de la
pénitentiaire qui viennent chercher Eric
pour l'emmener à 600 km en banlieue
parisienne
[Musique]
quand on est confronté à la
pénitentiaire quand c'est ce qui nous
attend
et menottes ils entravent
on peut pas faire autrement
on doit se plier à la discipline
[Musique]
désormais il devra gérer sa maladie tout
seul
[Musique]
trop envie de pouvoir
me donner les moyens pour pour m'en
sortir devenir quelqu'un
je rêve de refaire ma vie
[Musique]
cela fait maintenant 10 mois que nous
sommes arrivés pour la première fois à
Cadillac pour ceux qui sont loin de leur
famille l'approche de Noël c'est
toujours un moment compliqué cette
histoire de Noël tout le monde la
connaît c'est la naissance de Jésus
celui qui est venu sur la terre pour
sauver tout le monde dans cette petite
célébration toute simple de Noël qu'on
fait ici à l'UMD on vient dire merci
Jésus voilà merci Seigneur
allez on va se mettre debout pour tous
les ans le prêtre de la paroisse vient
dire la messe tous ceux qui le
souhaitent peuvent y assister
[Musique]
aujourd'hui catholique ou non ils ont
une cinquantaine à prier tous ensemble
[Musique]
c'est aussi notre dernier jour de
tournage depuis nous avons pris des
nouvelles des patients
[Musique]
Philippe vient de recevoir la valve des
médecins pour quitter l'UMD plus tard il
voudrait devenir bénévole dans une
association caritative
toujours délirant Michel devrait bientôt
aussi quitter Cadillac pour rejoindre
notre unité pour malades difficiles à
Albi
le corps du Christ là-bas une cousine se
manifestait
Jean-Pierre se bat toujours pour quitter
l'IMD mais son souci de moment c'est
qu'on autorise de nouveau atteindre ses
cheveux
pour voir si Daniel était capable de
s'adapter à un nouvel environnement
on l'a changé de pavillon ça faisait 12
ans qu'il était dans la même unité
[Musique]
son transfert s'est bien passé il
s'habitue à sa nouvelle chambre et peu à
peu cet oxapaise
[Musique]
tu vois que tu t'es amélioré
il est sorti de prison il a obtenu sa
liberté conditionnelle et aujourd'hui
il retrouve sa mère
[Musique]
il est toujours soigné à l'hôpital
psychiatrique de Cadillac
mais il pourra bientôt sortir le weekend
je vais pouvoir commencer une nouvelle
vie
c'est motivant
on s'accroche
quand il aura trouvé une place dans un
centre pour travailleur handicapé il
pourra sortir complètement de l'hôpital
en France 1% de la population serait
schizophrène mais seule une infime
minorité se retrouve dans des unités
pour maladies difficiles
[Musique]
la plupart ne passe jamais à l'acte il
trouve leur place dans la société
[Musique]